[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i am here guys give me one brief moment
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys let me turn my
mic down just a little bit
we don't want to bust people's eardrums
out
i might need this too
let me make sure you guys can't hear the
desktop audio that'd be
what's going on here all right all right
so everything's good
everything's good why so aggressive why
not
i've always been an aggressive
individual okay
you're going to have to forgive my
aggressiveness
forgive my aggressiveness you guys i got
to
hook up this
thing here so i can hear the audio
better
i really should have hooked this up
before
there we go
maybe worth the money i don't know we
ain't played it yet how am i supposed to
know if we ain't played it yet
there we go
all right can you guys see what's going
on look at that they want to update
they want to update already we ain't
trying to do the update
they really messing with us man they
messing with it
look at that they extended that man a
couple minutes ago
this i kid you not this said
an hour like a minute ago and now
and now it says this
no this is not octopath traveler
you know we will play just so you guys
have some amusement
we will play a game of fall guys
while i wait for this stupid game to
unlock
see i wouldn't have went live so soon if
i knew
that it wasn't going to go you couldn't
go
so let's see hold up people messenger me
give me a second
all right all right let's let's let's
let's get this going return
i can't wait
all right that should be good enough
amazon rewards
and what we'll do is this is a good
place to
test how the stream is running so
i want you guys to actually tell me
if the stream's running bad or not
i know sometimes i know sometimes you
guys don't do that
trying to trying to build myself up man
something other i i got nothing really
until this stupid game's unlocked i
don't have really nothing to do man
unless you guys just want to hear me
talk i mean i can definitely just talk
but you guys don't want to see my my my
awesome skills of fall guys is that
what's going on here
oh man already already
oh my god
if i lose i'm blaming you guys
i'm really making myself look really bad
right now on some fall guys
get up get up
talk is cool too i mean yeah i mean we
could do that
what do you guys want to see man that's
not our fault i'm blaming i'm always
blaming you guys
it's not in my nature to take the blame
for anything
put some tunes on i don't like okay
here's with the tunes
i don't know what's going to get us
banned and what's going to get his
copyright strike
so i'm kind of nervous about the tunes
man
nervous about the tunes
the dying has me already started look
man the game is going to start here in
probably about 20 minutes
i got me something to drink i'm ready
i'm ready i got this
freestyle send me send me some
some links on twitter man send me some
links on twitter i'll have to test it on
gaming addicts channel and then if it if
i don't get no copyright strikes i might
bring it over here
i don't know i felt very very uneasy
putting any kind of risk
oh
i like how they keep like redoing these
stages because this
usually wasn't on here
think i'm in first
there we go
uh i'm nervous about playing this game i
feel like i'm about to i'm about to look
really bad
oh i got a trophy for placing first
i'm excited i'm excited to try it i wish
it would just unlock
maybe one day your boy be big enough to
get review copy so you don't have to
wait
for the game to unlock man
oh this is the perfect match i actually
like this game
i wonder if they've changed it if they
have other stuff in here shooting at you
i feel like i'm ghostly like my my
avatar is like a ghost
all right so so let's we got this okay
i'm not falling here
i won't fall victim to an apple
unless one of these bozos throw me off
okay so here's a peach two peaches and
a banana banana peach
peach banana
what is it it's banana
oh i feel bad for that dude
okay uh watermelon grape
orange grape
watermelon grape orange watermelon grape
orange
watermelon grape orange orange orange
orange
all right cherry banana cherry banana
grape grape cherry banana
grape cherry banana
grape cherry banana grape cherry banana
oh i don't know which one it is
i'm i'm trusting them ah
they they they played me they played me
they played me
oh my god i can't believe that happened
they played me
i take full responsibility for that
returnal
22 minutes
we have 22 minutes
i actually do
hold up
wait sling
oh 22 minutes
this is a preview of return no it's
actually the same
the actual game you guys can see where i
met spider-man i'm like nothing special
with spider-man
i'm actually enjoying the game little by
little of what i played
i haven't really played my playstation
since i bought it off a kid
i kind of like if you want to think
about it's like kind of a waste of money
to buy this playstation
yeah i wish xbox would do that uh ricky
but we know how expo xbox will probably
get something like that
in the future
i'd assume
i'm about to put a time stamp in this
see i got his black suit
oh yeah that's right the chick the chick
was with the other people
right out about that
yeah playstation's decent at
presentation what i really
want them to do is like get gifting and
stuff like that's what they really need
they need gifting what
other games am i running what are you
talking about
like until this game comes out what am i
running
you have to explain what you mean by
that man recommendations
i don't like i've been playing a lot of
final fantasy
uh you know 10. there's a there's a
secret boss in this
i've never beat on final fantasy like
ever
why do i look so ghostly
i look so ghostly
hold up let me drop this down to like
five
all right maybe maybe that will fix the
ghostly portion man
it's good if playstation get a copy of
quick resume they do need their own
version of quick resume i will not argue
with you on that point whatsoever
now i don't know how many of you have
played
final fantasy 10 all right you have to
give me
some recollection in the chat if you've
played this game if you have remotely
played this game
but i'm so busted it's unreal i'm so
broken
and i'm still doing nothing
where turtle got you uh i don't know
what you mean by that man
see i got all a lot of the legendary
weapons
you see he one shots people but it don't
matter
i don't even remember what what ability
to use
i don't remember nothing about riku
so so out of curiosity what do you guys
think the odds of me getting out of the
first biome are
what do you think the odds of me getting
out of the first biomarker
i need opinions do you guys think i'm
gonna completely flop
let's just do two high poached and see
where that goes
four out of ten so you you guys are
thinking i have no
chance of getting to that i don't like
the way the energy in this
is going right now man i feel like i
deserve the benefit of the doubt
slim to none you guys are really playing
me like this
phil is playing gears 5 this man plays
so much
games bro he does phil plays a lot of
games
that's what i do like about phil is he's
a gamer
see now you saw how like that dude was
nothing right
i i had no real issue with him
he was quick work
now look at this dude
this is one of the hardest bosses in
final fantasy
the amount of work you have to do to
even fight this dude is ridiculous
and he's just as hard as the work that
you had to do to fight him
now watch how quick he makes me
bend the knee
it's interesting can you guys not hear
the uh
i don't think you guys can hear the
audio can you
why can't you hear the audio
this stuff i'll be talking about man
the audio definitely should be working
hold up return is not out
man it's out in 15 minutes to beat to
let me check see if you guys can hear
the gameplay hold up give me a second
why can't you guys hear the game play
it was playing earlier
oh my god hold up
i'd be hating this game loki like
the amount of extra stuff you have to go
through to make sure everything works
the way it's supposed to
is ridiculous
there's no reason why you guys can't
hear this
this gameplay i don't know why you can't
hear it
[Music]
let me take this back off
[Music]
[Music]
there we go you guys should be able to
hear it now
too loud
[Music]
all right what about now what about now
tell me if i got it right
is it is it still louder than me
what about now it's about halfway
you can't hear me
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm dead that's it folks
i might not die no i'm pretty much dead
the amount of difficulty this boss has
is just
it's just absurd
well if it's a little too low let me
raise it just a little bit
i raised it just a little bit
oh i'm straight up messing up this stuff
man
dead
gravitation man i don't dead
it's over
it's ridiculous man it's ridiculous we
got 10 minutes and 32 seconds left
1080p everything looks good
you guys say that the uh the audio is
coming out pretty well
so i don't think i have to worry about
the audio too much
[Music]
[Music]
this is final fantasy 2 until return is
ready in 10 minutes yes
i got off it because you guys are crying
man you don't like my final fantasy
level that's okay
man that's okay not everybody can can be
the goat
so now instead of watching game play
you're watching this and the only people
you can blame
is yourself because we was playing other
games
but you guys didn't want to watch any of
it you know let's go in the store
and you guys tell me up your own voice
all right all right i'll up it i'll up
it a little bit man i'll up it a little
bit
all right so tell me what is good games
for the playstation because you know i'm
never over here
ever what's good games for the
playstation
is anything on here worth wild
anything on here i should try
do any of you
agree with what i'm looking at
foreign
floppy here i don't know man it's
getting good reviews people are really
liking it uno
is uno on here yeah you know is on here
it's 3.99 too
yo let's let's look at playstation now
let's look at playstation now
where is it where is it
playstation now
so marvel avengers is on there until
june the 5th tokyo
jungle no
i'm not doing the tokyo jungle man it's
not happening
i can't trust you guys i can't trust
your opinions on it now
i i'm on playstation i can't play
xbox on my playstation i could probably
have them both hooked up to this to be
honest with you
is there any like converters you can do
for like an hdmi
where i could just switch a button it
goes back and forth between them
new to ps now let's see what's in ps now
world war z that's been in game pass
i'm not quite sure if this has been in
game pass or not uh
so second sun recently just went to game
pads that was a good game
super hot i don't know how i feel about
super hot but it is what it is man it is
what it
world
is
frostpunk's a good game bioshock
remastered i would probably play that
if i had an opportunity
let's see what it's at now man let's see
what it's at now
we're at six minutes and 30 seconds
second sun did not go to game obviously
it's a playstation game
hotline miami is a good game i don't i
was looking at the
the deals i don't really like the new
way they do the uh
the store but it is what it is i'm sure
some people like it
here's death loop
i wonder if this game's gonna be any
good i'm a huge um
i'm a huge fan of
of um
of arcane
look man i can't help it i cannot help
it we going over games right now
until this game unlocks
i actually like this this isn't game
pass by the way i own it on xbox too but
this isn't game best
the witcher you know i've never sat down
and really played the witcher
not one time
scarlet nexus if i get that it'll
probably be on a
on xbox most likely i don't really buy a
whole lot of games on playstation
you got their they can't get forza
horizon hot wheels edition so they get
hot wheels
unleashed
towers of a rise who's buying tells of a
rise
who is buying towels of her eyes
three minutes and 55
seconds
let me go and share it out now for
people that left and came back waiting
[Music]
[Music]
all right there we go
[Music]
how many chickens you sacrificed to own
this 70 dollar flop gaming addict
pose you being real messy right now man
you being real messy
look i played enough zelda to know you
don't mess with chickens
if the stream is late do we get a free
t-shirt
man i don't have no control over the
t-shirt it's got none whatsoever
it's still locked man like the the crazy
part is
when i i was looking earlier
it said that that it was like an hour
left
so i was all right i guess we're
starting at 11. so what i
did is i just started the the
the screen a little early but then when
i went in here and looked
it extended it by an hour
[Music]
oh the carnage the carnage solve
how you gonna super chat me 20 bucks
just this talk that smack
all right it is live in one minute
in 50 seconds i don't need your negative
opinions i want nothing but positivity
[Music]
i think i will put in the the car i
think i'll put in the description that
there is uh
just so people know when this actually
goes through
one minute in 15 seconds
actually let me get like a pillow or one
second
[Music]
[Music]
oh here we go i think the pillow might
be a little too much
liger334 we got to get you up out of
there man you can't be
saying that nonsense all right we want
with this game needs to start
right now and it is
[Music]
here we go man here we go
look look my my chair is a lot less
comfortable than it used to be
no i don't want any sound bar
[Music]
there's no other audio put besides sound
bar do they think everyone's just got a
sound bar
i mean i have the thing but it doesn't
work because there's
i can't use the headset and hear the
game
i have to use this connected to the
actual tv
all right let's do this return isn't
intended to be a challenging experience
each new cycle presents new challenges
rewards changes to the world adapt and
preserve to progress further
here we go man here we go ow that kind
of hurt i burnt myself a little bit
i wish i could get rid of that
oh my god
[Music]
gotta move everything back over here
all right there we go what's up fawns
there's concert narrative it's just like
you have to get far enough to actually
see the nerd
so pretty much how it's looking like
it's going is you're in a loop
and you have to get out of the loop and
every time you die
hopefully you get closer and closer to
another clue of what's going on in this
loop
that's what i've got come to like
understand when it comes to this game
oh that that's pretty cool it's raining
and you feel it on the controller
i survived but helios did not
suit status operational but my sidearm
is missing
i'm leaving comms open sidearm's missing
calms are open
abandoning helios heading towards white
shadow broadcast
all right here we go
appreciate for joining the realm snoozy
appreciate it man
you know iop every sunday at 1 pm is the
podcast that we are
man yeah i think if you gave it one one
try you would enjoy the show
what is this
i have found a deceased astro scout here
checking identification on a helmet it's
is it you
let's see the skills addict all right
man let's go
pick up that gun let's go when i got
time for you to see her be
memorized let's go
he got the gun
continuing towards the signal's origin
hold halfway down okay
how do i reload
why
how do i reload the game doesn't look
that bad
discovered a potential resource so
repairs moderate damage to
integrity i don't know what that means
yet
so it just re it heals you it looks like
that's all it does
requires a key we don't have a key oh
what is this
oh here's our first set of enemies first
set of enemies
i don't know how to reload rick we're
gonna have to move on with this
we can't spend our whole life trying to
reload
look at him man
what is this
looks like money of some sort
pretending recorded log found
adding to databank playing back now
scout log
elapsed time 30 minutes since last crash
whole areas of this forest are
rearranging themselves like
a fluid puzzle after each of my
when whenever i return
per astra protocol i will not be
recovered until i reach the broadcast
signal
if you're hearing this you are stuck
here too so
i'm hearing myself
hold for a longer dash press circle hold
for a longer dash okay
gotcha man hold for a longer dash
this one's
security system encountered
i wonder what you use this money stuff
for
so
all right so i hear someone else they
think they slick
yeah there's someone else here
open sealed gates in containers but is
infected
with a majesty i should probably go all
right so pretty much what's what's
saying here is may have negative
effector even and hey with certain
abilities
let's just do it let's pick it up man
what's the worst that can happen
suit manifold obviously that's the worst
that can happen
suffer damage with when using keys
that's the nonsense first one i pick up
is something like that
so someone said does the movement feel
like mass effect andromeda
i didn't play a whole lot of mass effect
so i couldn't really answer that
question to be honest with you
i've discovered piled corpses of a
xenotype species
likely the architects of these ruins
this could be the sentience that
broadcasts the white shadow signal
it is impossible to escape i have tried
everything
i'm always brought back by
there is a moment between death and
rebirth
when tentacles drag me down screaming
drowning returning
oh man he knocked me out
wow i gotta i gotta learn how to dodge
that move a little bit better
here we go man first death it definitely
was first death man
first death
think you were supposed to die there i
don't know
helios
astra this is celine i survived that
can you hear me i'm in my ship suit
status operational and
i've already experienced this before
just going to go ahead and go to sleep
you don't die over and over again if you
if you feel sleep
all right so this is how you get out
i like how they take advantage of third
person and first person
look man it is what it is
oh they they ain't even playing now it
wasn't like this before
hold up
oh what's
so the world's different
there's some parkouring stuff
new technology discovered grants
alternate fire
an alternative firing mechanism
all right so that's like a charge beam
highly effective this will be useful
oh why
i'm not feeling no ammo there we go
so
look at these
man there's a lot of them
is that all of them
and it'll attack i don't know what that
is
need something for it
game looks like it's set in a lead
universe
i think it is
oh god what is that
look at that man they try to play me
yeah i was trying to switch to a
shoulder view i don't know if you can or
not but i was definitely trying
not enough ether so you need ether to do
something here
i don't have any ether i don't even know
what ether is but i don't have any
oh what is this similar to our carbine
technology
i got a gun well
i've had a gun but now i got another gun
discovered a massive wall beyond which
is the white shadow signal
are you going to shoot me across the
chasm
for now i'll change objectives
and investigate the energy reading in
the forest
they ain't shooting me i ain't shooting
them we ain't starting b for no reason
the broadcast
we don't do that do you see the white
shadow is something
only i should know
i need answers to believe signal
oh i knew there was someone there
let's go
oh what is that
oh
what's up man i i appreciate everyone
coming
through man it's it's pretty good
outcome for considering
the game just came out
now what is this disable all turrets
within the area let's see what the other
one is
xenotype device acquired i think this
will prove a useful tool
i don't even know how to get to that to
be honest with you
i have interacted with other versions of
myself
but i worry one day i will re-experience
these same
interactions from their perspectives
but are they truly me or just hollowed
corpses
this may be the face of things to come
doing pretty good man doing pretty good
appreciate saying
why you running
oh they really want my they they really
want me dead don't they
hold that
discovered xenotype technology on the
corpse of a sentient
scan is indicating potential for suit
augmentation
i don't think it's a timed exclusive man
i think it's a permanent exclusive
appears safe to repurpose
system integration complete performing a
function test to confirm
all right let's see here you should
cannot translate to teleport okay so it
says blue things
confirmed point-to-point teleportation
location exit seems fixed
you gotta need like a double jump or
something i guess
suit integrity increased okay
can i climb this
oh what is this
oh man i don't know what to do man left
right or middle tell me which one man
left right or middle
i'm very nervous about this i feel like
about to mess up
left all right
felt like that could have went really
bad for me
oh
oh yeah this teleporter now
oh let's get rid of this thing
okay so this is ether
consumable i don't know how to consume
these to be honest with you
uh
discovered xenotype technology that
produces other devices
fabricators okay so
i got enough for none of that
yeah i'm doing it so far
evidence of rudimentary xenotype
language discovered
currently lacking resources to decipher
this evidence
discovered a fragment of the xenotype
language
detecting a strange energy reading
setting a marker on my map
where's that other green one where is he
okay so it was just one
so
i don't know what the blue doors are yet
where you at
it's a shotgun
i don't know i feel about i'm going back
for that i don't want to use a shotgun
i feel like a lot of these people are up
close and i don't want to be restricted
to
having a fire from from a close range
oh i'm recharging
oh
last shell i don't want that
stay higher ground
whew
i just don't like that man
all right let's see here
what is that all right so
you can't hold on to different weapons i
don't know okay mega
i wasn't trying
i like the weapon i have down i wasn't
risking not being able to hold both
oh
oh what is this
um
what's up fourteen one death so far
one death
fabricate items they talk about that one
place
all right so i got rid of whatever that
was
i had it got clapped because i'm pretty
sure attic was supposed to get clat
notice i ain't fought one of those
things since i got clapped by it
sir tell the whole story sir
this way to open up that door i just
don't know what yeah
what is this
oh i'm not feeling this
what's going on oh someone's living here
i think i am reliving my memories in
that house but
not fully they're corroded
some parts are missing others seem
manufactured but i can't
remember the torment feeling like i was
losing my mind
there's no comfort here no safe space
what's that sound and the astronaut
keeps following me
yep i knew i was about to get wasted
there
oh he's chasing me down
broken caliber i have no clue what that
is
fascinating i've discovered a kind of
technology that records
past or a visual archive of sorts
they built protection this must have
occurred
centuries ago
okay this is very high
should i open it i feel like i should
let this stay right here
whatever's in this chest i feel like i
should not mess with
whatsoever
and i'm i'm not even listening to the
chat cause you
you guys are gonna play me man
you guys gonna tell me to open it and
it's gonna get me killed
do it for content you know what all
right man
you guys win you guys win
you guys win
dude i'll cancel it you can't be holding
me ransom like that that's not cool
oh
got an upgraded version of the gun i had
so i haven't tried up here
is a checkpoint or a teleportation
device
aries locked down oh it's one of these
things
oh oh i see you
i see you
i want nothing to do with you man
get away
jump up here
yeah hold that now it's time for me to
run
i'm not fighting you there either we
fighting on my terms or we're not
fighting at all
it's a sound
you know what i'm gonna try it even if i
die i'm gonna try i'll come back for
that if it's not good
oh it's these things again
oh hit me
they hit my noggin man they got me
pretty good there
i don't even know if that was worth it
so i don't have any manufacturings right
now so
those are kind of
look man that was the plan not to get
clapped
i'm picking this back up
appears to be another teleportation
device but more complex in construction
discovered a broken automaton clutching
a potential tool
appreciate everyone sharing the stream
on twitter and stuff
i see you guys
how do i use it
requires a crimson key
oh
okay
i get it we getting somewhere
come on
what's this
oh it's the house housekeeper we can go
in the house now man
game's over we in the house we done
just go in there and sleep we don't need
to do all this extra stuff
huh
so far so good
i don't even know where that house was
to be honest with you
i feel like it's right here
all right here we go here we go
this
i did not go this way
encountered a small life
seen alien enough time to know where
this is going don't pick that up
oh my gosh
it is parasitically attached to my arm
does not appear hostile
somehow it's strengthening
and weakening my suit
to access your stats press
all right so
so my all fire cooldown is increased by
five percent
so it takes longer for that gun to show
up
but i find more often okay i think i
think that's a good
trade-off to be honest with you
i thought that was a dog for a second
she's literally went crazy
let's see what's over here
hmm
what is this
oh it's a key
oh they're behind me
oh
so
oh that's awesome yeah let's not break
those again
i need a key for that
i need collect 250 of those it looks
like to get rid of whatever
i have
doable
oh i bet you that's where the boss room
is
do i really want to go in there like
this though
i have one in this room let's go in this
room first
i'll leave this stream look man i might
do it just to see if you will
man my god i might have to test you
yeah let's go fight the boss i think
that's the boss i don't know
it looks like a boss type of room
so the little vine things
minus 30 in damage
oh god oh god
a strange energy source is beyond this
it might be tied to white shadow
what is this no
i'm nervous i'm nervous i don't know if
i should jump
off
i
oh i'm so nervous
[Music]
hmm
oh god
oh
damn man
it gets up on me you have to be
constantly moving when you fight it
crash again
astra
they can't hear me
i'm alone
all right i don't think the game looks
last
gen to be honest with you i got
what is this
discovered a strange device that is
already active it feels
alive
i'm not receiving any information from
scanning
ah i have no clue what
just happened
the environment is changing could the
force be adapting
all right so you do keep your you tell
you do keep the stuff like you teleport
stuff all right
wow
one of my corpses was still functioning
it attacked me and
i killed myself
i need to believe it was nothing
different than the other hostiles i
dispatched but
was it or was it another version of me
just trying to escape
this game's this game's like real
crazy i just killed myself
oh can't get in the water okay got you
we got another gta on our hand we can't
swim
huh
i guess you can't get in the water man i
don't know what's going on
water is not something that you're able
to do in this game
that's the beginning
there's a door up there i wonder how i
get to it
it is kind of weird you can't get in
water but i'm not gonna really
like hate on it because of it
oh
all right all right
what about a better swing
oh
this is about a middle mid weapon
visuals look good visual is definitely
a good amount of uh like it's not
disappointing or anything like that
oh
oh this
oh yeah it's got a red barrier
gotta be on the run
[Music]
oh
oh my god
enough i understand
i'm trapped the broadcast signal
that's all that matters astra
helios is gone celine heading out
knew i would be coming back
oh
ah
whew
i'm waiting oh you guys are so
wrong man can't get playstation anything
can you man
i gotta start remembering
enhanced melee attack
oh
i don't know how this got upgraded but
i'm not going to question it
oh it's one of these things
what's this
get up man
appreciate it
atl that my bad my bad
put you in your name man my bad
increase speed of weapons for the next
15 kills
sure
no i don't know i like what i have right
now
oh
oh there's a red one over here
oh
oh i lost it
oh
need some sunlight find a window is my
stuff really that dark should i like
because i have a i have a light behind
my monitor i can make it lighter if you
go
if that's really an issue
hmm
oh the game hold up
i don't think there's like anything i
can do about that
items in a teleporter is kind of
annoying
oh one of these things
oh god
ah
uh
oh
look man that was a that's a rough
uh rough area there's a lot of people in
that area
wow
so you keep the key
exactly as i left it but impossible
does the game have multiplayer i don't
have a ps5 and
game wouldn't really compel me to get
one
oh yeah i mean it does i don't think it
has multiplayer but
i loved my first missions in this binder
but this is stored in the mother ships
archives
this was taken after i left
why
give me some pt vibes man
hello who is up there
i can't
pansy i'd pick that up
such strange markings
oh god got pinhead going on here
man you guys are ridiculous
game feels more like a job oh my gosh
what is that she said something about
astronaut remember
what is this meant to tell me
am i supposed to remember this
all right here we go
astronaut figure personal item it will
never it will
not let you go
okay
i hate these flying things
where's that green thing
uh
oh my god
oh god
went to look at the chat and got messed
up
i'm most likely gonna die but
we gonna keep trying man
yeah they've been real messy in that
chat man they're being real messy
i need four more
i'm not gonna lie i'm not feeling like
the map design
for the mode i don't know i'm not trying
to have a pistol
uh
so it looks like some of them don't
respawn
what happened with that boss fight i got
i got clap that's what happened i lost
i came here once and died
so far so good looks like this is like
the boss
area
oh no i've been here before
mmm
i love how she knows how to use these
machines
oh yeah this is where what's his name
was
what is this this is where i die
i gotta get close to him
oh
come on up here
uh
hit something but not what i wanted it
to
where is this thing
there we go got my thing back
what you guys arguing about in the chat
let me let me just
see what's going on yeah the swords
definitely i actually got a perk that
makes it stronger
what's that red door
what you guys arguing about man put it
in the chat what you guys arguing about
i feel left out
i'm pretty
it looks like it's already open
oh it's on
oh it was open oh my god
so can i like go straight to the boss
going straight to the boss would be
suicide
my end is waiting at the beginning
abandoned like helios fast drive
failed escape fatal crash
my memories have been rearranged into
spiral patterns
i cannot comprehend dragging me into the
deepest
of the deep i will go there now
as you will
god this one over here to the right
somewhere
uh
so they glow when they about to clap you
okay
i got it the globe
ow
what is this
uh
foreign
guys man it's okay it's okay we're gonna
live
everything's going to be okay
what's this thing again
oh my god
well that was that was terrific
yeah come over here buddy
[Music]
buddy
buddy
uh
i don't like how your adrenaline gets
reset automatically for one attack
i feel like it should tickle a couple i
feel like i should take a couple
to reset it completely
gotta find a key
i don't like that gun i'd like to have
the carving
don't like that's gun
if i just had my hands on like just
one a carving i would feel so much
comfortable
oh god
it's the one where you climb it ain't it
nope just teleport
yeah you climbed this
huh
so
i'm like loki i'm already getting tired
of the like the repeated areas
gotta bust that shield unfortunately
see
i won't give up
all right you guys
yeah okay i'm done for the night because
i'm tired and i have an eight
i like the game i like the combat
i just feel like there's just like
something missing
like the way you build up isn't really
properly like explained to you
and i assume that
the boss room is still open
and i and i appreciate they give you
like little things that you could do
that you can upgrade your certain things
and no one's saying that it's not good
good like the majority
of the people in this game
they're pretty predictable so far like i
i'm good with patterns
the more i fight than the you know the
better i'm just gonna get in general
it's just like to me i mean it's like
you said gomez like
i've already there's the the one where
you go
up the teleporter then you go down
there's the one where you have like the
tree going up
like i've only played it for an hour and
a half to two
and i'm already seeing like the same
things be used over and over again i
mean that's not
bad
i'm gonna have to i'll play it some more
i am going to play it more
i just got to get i got to get a better
understanding
of how the power ups and stuff work i
think that's the biggest thing that
i'm confused by right now is how the
power ups and stuff work
but the game's fun it is it's just
i need a little bit more understanding
how certain things operate
yeah that's probably another thing
lingers
so far there's not like a real love what
mechanic in the game
and i mean that could be good or bad it
doesn't necessarily mean the game's bad
it's just i'm used to a certain thing
so there is going to be a multiplayer
added to this like i'm going to still
play this
probably after the demon soul stream
that we do on iop
i'm going to go back to return it's just
right now like when i pick up
an ability i feel like it's useless
maybe i need to test around with them a
little bit more
and you know i just died again and
you know you you look at the map i mean
obviously the map starts back over
but i i don't feel like what's what i'm
looking for
i don't feel no motivation to just keep
doing this
like a lot of the map looks alike too so
sometimes i'm getting a little bit
lost it's not necessarily loss you just
bring up the ma
the overall map and you'll find where
you need to go
let me see if the boss is open
so the bus is open
i like to fight the boss a couple more
times
because he does this then he does the
fire move where
that comes out then he throws the fire
after it
but you know it's pretty easy to dodge
i don't know how much damage i do with
the sword
nothing not enough to worth going in
there again
i gotta get used to when he when he
comes close to clap me man
that's what he's doing the most damage
yeah see then he does that jump over
this
start shooting
oh
oh he did two of them
he surprised me i didn't expect to
i won't give up
mommy you can't give up you're kind of
stuck in the loop
all right you guys i'm uh in the stream
uh what we're going to do
is monday we're going to continue demon
souls
and then we're going to finish demon
souls and we'll come back to return
so far it's a good game i enjoy i do
feel like there's a couple design
choices i would have chose a little bit
different
yeah the story makes sense like to me
what's going on is she she's stuck in
some kind of loop
and all the other bodies that she's
finding
is herself because they're all trying to
find out what's going on
besides that that's all i really know
because that's all they've really told
me
i haven't really got far in the game
yeah the boss fight wasn't really that
difficult as you can see i almost beat
him
he had about maybe seventy percent of
his health on the last
bar i had a i had a pistol you guys
a pistol
i wonder if you could see where the boss
is
if i could get my hands on another
carbine i think i could beat that boss
it'd be different let me see if i could
i'll do one more life
to see if i can find the boss
is it i mean i don't know i have to see
like exactly what they do next
i haven't played enough for the game to
determine if it's worth something or not
oh that's bull
no the boss gets his health back up
that's the second time i fought the boss
i think that takes me straight to the
boss if i follow that
i see brap is streaming this i'm tempted
to take the whole stream over there and
see what's up see how he's doing
i'm tempted
oh god
oh i got a lock down
a lock down
i don't like that ability
one
whew
so it looks like you might keep either
see once again we're gonna go around
here there's gonna be portal to the left
yep
this is going to take us probably the
tree area
oh you follow me in here
i i didn't try to hit it under the fog
oh brad's already streamed
he's already streamed man he's gonna pop
in there and see what he was doing man
was going to but we can't anymore
oh yeah i see what you talking about
that
i don't think i need to do that though
like for the most part
wasn't trying to fight them man
oh unfortunately i lost a bunch of
health on axe
man wow
uh
where does this go
oh yeah this crimson key thing
gotta get that green
what's up smitty smith
oh i needed that
i'm not even trying to get in there last
time i got in water i died
i need five years to close
i just want to get to the boss man
oh the boss
yeah i wasn't trying to go in the water
again last time i tried to kill me i
wasn't trying
to relive that failure
you know what guys i'm gonna call it a
night i'm tired
but i appreciate everyone that coming by
that we streamed
for a while for about two two hours
you know two and a half hours
technically if you want to count when i
was playing fall guys waiting for this
stuff to boot
but i appreciate everyone coming by man
we'll see you we see you sunday
i'll play